ha
re
me
t
こんにちは
えっ東京は科学の話をするということなんだけど
越冬皆さんは科学者っていうのは
だいたい白衣着て顕微鏡をのぞいているとか
フラワー柄試験管振っているとかコンピューターの前で計算してるって言う姿を
思い浮かべ
僕も科学者ですで僕の仕事はフィールドサイエンスいって野外でからですねほとんど
山の中とか川とか海とかであります
だからこういう格好をして
いろんなところで
山々をあるいは彼はを監査するということがすごく重要な仕事になるわけですね
で a ただですねえっ一番大事なことっていうのは何か
えっと今日は8僕らが普段
フィールドで頭の中でやっている仕事をみなさんに少しご紹介したいと思います
越冬僕らがものお山に川に野外でものを考えるときはまず最初よく見る
っていうことが基本なんですねよく見るで見たものをまずは頭の中で考える深く考える
じっと考えそして考えたものをこの後は学校で皆さんがなっている
プロトコルでいわゆる手続き計算するとかそれから
へ
実験するとかへ
あるいは解析するとかいったことをやってまぁ科学を正
ゴールするわけですがこの考えるというところが実は一番大事なんですね
今日はここをいくつかご紹介したいと思いますで野外で価格をしていると本当にも
考えることだけが勝負です
でこれはいくつかの例のうち一つですがまず視覚化っていう作業頭の中でよくあります
で心に見えるのは単に星空です
ねこれを見ても皆さん何も見えなくただ
星が見えてるだけだと思う人もいるかもしれないけどここに riri 社時代に正座
っていうことを考えたいと思いますね星座っていうのはいろいろあるんだけどもまぁ人
の形だと過信はビール写真はそれから
ものの形とかありますがこれは北斗七星ですね柄杓の方
アーチの星座を視覚化したわけです
でここからこの視覚化した衛星座から皆さんよくご存知5倍伸ばすと北極星
年中いうかな北極星見つけることができるわけですねでへコンピューターがこういう
ことであれば一つ一つの法事小山ゆっくり時かあーゆーくり通り座標に追い続けて
覚えるということですが
星座
いうことを視覚化することだってこんな便利なことに使える
それから厚木にまあ二巻体系化といったことですが昔こっち側にあるように交差嘘だと
か水素だとかいろんな元素についてバラバラバラバラ大昔は
へ
研究していたんですがああこれをある時遠くのほうからグーッと眺めて俯瞰して少し
構造的に体系化しましょうということでを作った
で縦に秋季電子のはの数ですねそれから横軸に族で一番外の電子のかをまあやって縦と
横へ整理するとこんな風に数色
べ
で霊符の主企業といいますがこのすごいところっていうのは実はこうやって整理する
ことによってこの区画になっているところ
白いところに後の人があるはずの元素を見つけることができたんですね
興銀全体を俯瞰することによってこういう芸当もできるということになります
で次
これは単純かそれからあー類推アナロジーっていうことですがここの左上の方に地球の
頭が世界の地図がありますが
a これを bot ただ見てるとただ何も思いつかないで皆さんここに何を見ますか
えっと例えば南北アメリカの東海岸ですねそれから
へ
アフリカからヨーロッパにかけての西海岸を見ると平行に a 走っているのがわかる
大陸の端9話で上ゲラーって人はこれをくしゃっとくっつけると一つの大陸になると
いうことまあたまたま思いついたわけです
でであればここがそうなんであれば他のところもそうなんじゃないかとも類推できる
わけですね
それで世界中のを大里甲くっつけた結果へ
こんな風になりますねだんだんランナーくっついていって最後は一つのパンゲアで
でっかい大陸になる
この結論したいはあの正しくはなかったんですがこの考え方を使って今やあプレート
テクトニクスということで皆さんの地震を予知することができるようなということに
なります
一つメタファー日言っていうねこれはよく皆さんも使うことですが昔から道路っていう
のは渋滞するということになるね
常楼道路渋滞自然渋滞だとかそれから事故があって渋滞とかありますがこの渋滞って
いうのは自動車も渋滞した実は水の流れの川だとか様々な流れの銃隊東方同じ
ように比喩することができでこういうふうに両方を比喩することが非常にわかりやすい
例えになって視覚的に分かるすぐはから理解できる
もう一つ
攻略一番大事なところですが復元えっとまぁ自然現象というのは一つの事件なんですが
事件をもう1回へ我々の目の前で再現できるようにいくつかの証拠を合わせて
作り直さなければいけ
この絵はこれ写真は馳走ですねちそうでこの地層の中に実は化石ってのは別もあって
エコの化石を順番に時代ごとにつなぎ合わせていくと皆さんよくご存知の進化系統樹と
いうのはできる
で人間の前はサルで猿の前を四脚さらにもや釈迦なぜといったのはこういう系登場
化石から丹念にいつないでいくことによって自然を過去の見えない線を復元することが
できたわけですね
こういったことでと価格の証拠を集めて新しい a
その自然現象のあった本来何が起こったかということを目の前に再現することができる
ということになります
で a さて a これ以外にもあるんですがいくつか紹介したのは視覚化俯瞰カー
リース eu 単純化復元ということですがこういった繋がりや実は我々頭の中で綺麗
に分かれているわけではないんですねで絵本たも一緒になって中にこう
混在してるんですが今日は皆さんに示すためにあえてこう
陸奥生きる
開けたで私は僕はあのこういう格好しているのは実は事前災害の研究をしています
自然災害特に土砂災害といって洪水土砂災害といって
山が崩れたり溜まったり滑りが起こったりいろいろ
いろんなこういった現象を眺めながら研究しているわけですがこういった
現象を流れる時もその中に何を見つけるかってのは先ほど言ったようなものを考え方
ってのはすごく大事な重要なファクターになってきます
それをこの中に子導入して今日はまあ言ってみればこの写真に写ったのは材料ですね
それからこの今こう並べたのは料理の料理の仕方
材料と
料理の仕方レシピですねのようなものですでいろんな材料があってどういうレシピの
材料調理法するのかレシピがあるのかによって様々な料理ができるということです科学
もまったく同じことになります
えっと今色々ありましたけれどもあれを漠然と見ていてもタダ
え
自然山が崩れた川が流れただけなんですがこれをまず単純化して
へメタファーしますでどう単純化するか
まず崩れる現象とたまる減少とそれから流れる減少とこの3つに分ける段重化する
でこうやって見ると一つの流域の中で
悲哀社員へ変更
ためたものを使ってエネルギーを出したり足を解体します
で最後は余ったものを廃止するということでこれまサインた
崩れるって事は赤はの利益の中に土砂がを食べるそれから流域の中に貯める
それから最後は雨も上がった元ものを流すという3つインエメタパすることができる
わけ
ですねでこう考えるとじゃあどうなるかということで実際におなかの中の
おなかの中の症かどういうふうに食べ物がたまって消化していくかということがキーに
なるわけです
そこを明らかにするためにじゃあはかりましょうということで実際まあこれは私が僕は
10年間二買った結果なんですがこういう風にして土砂の量をな館の中の食べ物おりを
測りますで人間もそうですが
食べたものが順調に
ちょっと汚いですけども排泄されれば健康ですね
だけども食べてなかなか便秘して排泄されないとか言うことがあるこれ災害なんですね
災害だから食べたものがサラサラでていけばいいんですがそれがたまるっていうことが
災害を起こし原因なんです
でそういうことでどういうし溜まっていくのが遠い場合にたまるのか
っていうことをはっきりしたせんでえこれ今あ1993年って書いてるところで
思いっきり同社食べてるわけですね
食べましたそれから上流下流にカ所で測っていますがどちらにも共通していることだ
ショー多少凸凹ありますがこれを単純化してみて
こういうふうに上流もカレーも行くどちらも格子
数的にこう収束していくなはかわかりますかね広
一つなたにでこれは上流も軽いも得も共通したことです枚食べたものが
へ
一定の時間をもこの場合10年後10年経つと消化してしまうということはね
猫の紹介するとまぁ一定の量に落ち着くんだという
こういうことが分かりましたこのことはちょっと頭の中に置いておいて欲しいんですね
ただですね
1回だけじゃなくてたびに息ももそうだけど食べて出して食べて出していく何回も
繰り返して生き続けるわけですね
それと同じようにえっと自然災害というのも食べて出しを繰り返しますで a 僕は今
1回の食べて出してっていうプロセスを再現することができたんですがそれを長い時間
にわたってみ
必要があるしかしそんな長い時間って人間生きてないからなかなか再現するのは難しい
誰かその自然の中で長い時間記録してくれてる人はいないのかっていう時に
森林っていうのはですね森林というのは実は a 1回
破壊される一番上にありますが破壊されると次に何もなくなっ
ドクサが入ってくるね種が入ってくると次には太陽5-8寿と液が入って
ダンダンダンな木が成長しておっきい上るになります
でへその森がまたあ
マージスターバン撹乱と言いますが書く欄が入ると一部あっ消える
rexer ないまあこういった事を繰り返して心理や回っていくわけでこのことを
利用して森林のありようから森林の在り様から
へ一体囲いないがあったほかということを推定します
向かって左側の上のしっぽ写真ですねこれはさっきした一番
撹乱されていない成熟した森林ですところが右母の写真と比べてもらうとずいぶん違い
ますね
右かを写真ではへ
大きな不凍液が何本かあってその真ん中にい
見ろい青々した緑緑した小さな木がもうも同じような気が入ってい
っていうことがわかりますこれは実は大きな洪水があってここは一旦中の全部
撹乱された後でこの大きな木が入ったんですね
でこの木がいつ入ったかっていうのを調べると1954年だと
年利を調べるんですねそれからええっもう一つちいさきこれは次の洪水が起こったとき
にまたこの大きな木以外が流されて
後入っていこれ一茶1971円だとわかるそれからさらにここへ入ってるギーの大きい
起きるとすべての記念りの中にここにこういう傷が入ってる
ます
こういう傷を見つけるすべてを気に入ってるのでこれを見つけると何年前にここにもう
1回構成があったっていうのか
これ実は分析すると
1993年
つまりさっき1993年に起こってから
へ
ガサッと土砂を食べたそれから出していたプロセスをお見せしましたがそれはこれから
後の話なんですね
実はその前に同じような事が1971円と1954年と2回も怒ってたということが
わかるわけです
これはもし僕は自分で観測しようと思ったらええええ
3歳のころから調査しなきゃ分からないことなんです
が機を利用する心理を利用することにこういったことがこれでも復元することでき
見たことない自然のプロセスがもう1回 a
目の前に表す言葉ですでそれはルイスいってね
でまぁさっきのデータはここにありますがこれと同じことが1971年1954年に
起こったするとじつはここの流域というのは a やだいたい中18件の感覚で食べる
でそれを8年から10年かけて出す排出する
でそうするとですね下流に言える人はこの災害遭わないためには予測するためには中
18年ごとに気をつければいい
それからそれから災害が起こってから8から10年経つと方
安心した状態のこういうことがわかるわけです
これは自然の状態ながら隠されたまあ位とってが秘密ですねそれを
を探り当てるということになります
今日は科学のお話をしたんですがえ
こういう考え方っていうのは僕らがフィールド野外で自然と向かい合ってじっと考えて
へ
いるときに使う
頭の
働き方なんだけども実は皆さんが遠い場面でも使うんですね
例えば仕事をしているときそれをあれ家事を取水路する選択するあり運動したり読書し
たり遊んでいろんな時に良い学校で習う事っていうのは一切鋼鉄好きなプロとくダネ
だけどもこの考えるって事は中々学校で教わらないんだけど
も考えてことを支えは家事も順調にやれ選択するのも人よりうまくできるし掃除も早く
できる料理もさせたときいろんなことが
a このを考えるという部分今日お見せしたような例えば6つくらいお見せしたような
施工方法を使えば
早くできるそれからへ
バックできるということができますでへまああの学校で教えてくれないねじゃあところ
に勉強するんだというくれ
残念ながらこれは皆さんが考え自分で本屋のい自分で考え自分で経験するってか学んで
いくということしかないですね
そうだってもしこれがマスターできたら皆さんの普段ももう少してほしくなっていく
ありがとうござました
[拍手]